good evening welcome to these four amis
of Hillsdale College I'm Matthew
Spalding
I'm the Kirby chair of the
constitutional government and I'm also
the Dean of our programs here in
Washington DC where we teach
undergraduates and soon we'll be
starting a graduate school here in
Washington DC as well of course
Hillsdale College is not in Washington
DC pursuits to observers view it's in
Hillsdale Michigan
it's an old college founded by Mitel
just as a point of reference question
dentally found I'm staying here 18:44
and as their game was chartered in
Indiana because of Hillsdale see in
history it was the first college to
prohibited targeting discrimination
based on race religion or sex it was an
early proponent of the abolition of
slavery Angeles today to this day takes
no federal money to maintain its moral
intellectual independence because of all
those things though still is always
emphasized not only the teaching of
liberal arts but the teaching of those
things necessary for perpetuation of
civil and religious liberty and that
means understanding principles and
practices of silver indeed is part of
our core we require every students of
Costa College to take a class on the
United States Constitution which briefly
to our the this evening and in our
conversation with
Multimedia commentary judge Baron de
graduate of Rhodes College with a BA in
English literature which I point out is
that when your earlier further heavens
that liberal arts or a property and good
foundation for good legal reasoning she
serves the Faculty of learning Law
School where she earned her JD some a
commodity and with a law clerk for judge
Lawrence suburban of the US Court of
Appeals for the DC Circuit and for
Associate Justice Kenton Scalia the
Supreme Court from 2010 to 2016
she served by a point of she's Justice
Roberts on the Advisory Committee for
the federal rules of appellate procedure
she's written for constitutional law etc
interpretation in numerous journals law
journals and as mere discussed earlier
she team still teaches one course every
semester at Notre Dame and she was
appointed the United States Court appeal
to the Seventh Circuit in November of
2017
after a few prepared bars remarks will
be interviewed this evening by Stephanie
Maloney Stephanie is an appellate
associate and Washington DC office of
instant and strong she served as a law
clerk to with judge Edith Clemente
of the United States Court of Appeals
for the Fifth Circuit and Judge Stephen
Murphy the United States District Court
for the Eastern District of Michigan she
graduated in our day in law school where
she the student of in professor Barrett
so with that a judge very well know
College
[Applause]
thanks so much to dr. Spaulding for
organizing this event
I am the lightning be with you this
evening I am a big fan of Hillsdale
College I have interacted with Phil's
Dale faculty and students and alumni
both social and academic contests
contacts and I am very impressed with
the education that Hillsdale has not
offered so I particularly delighted to
be with you here tonight I'm going to
talk this evening about the obligations
of duty in the face of private
preferences and the obligation of duty
in the face of intense public pressure
to the contrary and I'm going to begin
with the story from the Revolutionary
War era John Adams representation of the
British soldiers who had been involved
in the Boston Massacre the Boston
madness massacre happened in 70 sent me
at that point tensions between the
British POTUS and Lewis microphone over
British sivanna's and the crown were
rising so tensions were I British
soldiers for stations in Boston and
there was no love lost between the
British soldiers and the Bostonians the
Boston Massacre recanted and those of
you have been to Boston and found the
Freedom Trail have seen the sight of
this the bus demands were taunting the
soldiers who were stationed there and
what began and taunts then turns into a
crowd of three to four hundred people
erupts in its wartime singing
the British soldiers shouted to the
crowd killing five people the soldiers
were charged with murder and there was
no public sympathy for them to say the
least
there were a lot of public pressure
pressure for them to simply be lynched
they couldn't find counsel to represent
them and then John stepped up now
obviously John Adams of the patriot so
he could have felt a lot of personal
sympathy for the British soldiers he
wasn't his sympathies were not allied
with bears but he believed that it was
vital that British soldiers received his
fair trial
he believed that the American cause for
such government to be harmed if Boston
justice was not truly just and so he
agreed to represent the soldiers and he
was reviled
by many was Tony Anna's for doing his
own he faced intense public pressure
about that decision about his choice to
represent the enemy and here's what
Adams and so nice to say about it I
devoted myself to endless labor and
anxiety if not to infamy and to death
and that for nothing except what was and
ought to be all and all a sense of duty
John Adams put aside personal
preferences he stood up to public
pressure and he did his duty and
moreover he did it to the best of his
ability he didn't do his grudging
minimal best he did his absolute best
and the captain was acquitted and most
of the soldiers were and those who were
not escaped the death penalty
now John Adams did these things as a
lawyer but adhering to duty in the face
of a contrary personal or political
preference and in the face of public
pressure to the contrary has particular
resonance for the job of a judge a judge
is obligated to apply the law as it is
and not as she wishes it would be
she's obliged to follow the law even
when her personal preferences cut the
other way or when she will experience
great public criticism for doing so
I'm going to talk about this with a
focus on the Supreme Court because those
are the cases with which you will be the
most familiar and the judges who you'll
be familiar with we have been fortunate
in our history to have justices who have
been willing to do their duty even when
it may run against their personal
sympathies and even when it will subject
them to public criticism many give you
an example from a famous dissent the
dissent of Justice Robert Jackson in the
case of Korematsu versus the United
States that case challenged the
constitutionality of the order
commanding exclusion of the Japanese
from certain areas during World War two
the imposition of curfews exclusions and
ultimately the Japanese internment is a
stain on American history as a
congressional Commission later described
it the internment was motivated by
racial prejudice war hysteria and a
failure of political leadership but the
widespread public support for the
Japanese internment is reflected in the
fact that Earl Warren who was then
Governor of California and later became
our Chief Justice who led the court when
Brown versus the Board of Education was
decided supported the Japanese
internment it was a time of war and
people were carried away now the
internment of the Japanese derived its
authority from an executive order that
had been signed by Franklin Delano
Roosevelt Robert Jackson owed his career
to Roosevelt Roosevelt had appointed him
to the three jobs that are the most
prestigious that any lawyer can have
Robert Jackson appointed him to be the
Solicitor General of the United States
the Attorney General of the United
States and he appointed him to his seat
on the Supreme Court and in addition to
their professional relationship they
were friends longtime friends that were
both from New York yet Jackson did not
allow whatever personal loyalty or
affection that he had for Roosevelt
influenced his decision in that case
unfortunately he was in the minority his
was a dissent the court decided six
three that the exclusion order was
constitutional but Jackson wrote a
vehement dissent objecting to the
constitutionality of an order that
rounded up people many of them most of
them American citizens simply because
they were of Japanese descent he argued
that that could not be justified as an
exercise of military power
there had been no suspension of habeas
corpus and that is the provision in the
Constitution that permits the exercise
of that kind of emergency power duty not
politics being a judge takes courage the
courage of Robert Jackson you are not
there to decide cases as you may prefer
you are not there to decide cases as the
public or as the press may want you to
you're not there to win a popularity
contest you are there to do your duty
and to follow the law wherever it may
take you
Justice Scalia used to say that a judge
who likes every result that she reaches
is not a very good judge in fact she's a
very bad judge the law simply does not
align with the judges political
preference or personal preference in
every case and so it will be the case
that judges have to make hard decisions
and that they have to decide cases in
ways that yield outcomes that are not
the outcomes they would prefer I've been
at this only for about a year and a half
and I can attest that that has happened
to me many times already but that is the
duty of a judge to decide cases in the
way that the law requires them to be
decided and not simply you know from the
hip if I'm saying what would Amy Barrett
like to see the result in this case be
if the judge is willing not to apply the
law but to decide cases in a line in
accordance with personal preference
rather than the law then she's not
actually functioning as a judge at all
she's functioning as a policymaker the
fact that every judge wears a
nondescript black road I think is a
powerful testament to this fact it
symbolizes the impersonality of the law
and the dedication that each judge
should have to the rule of law the black
robe was not the custom of the nation at
its beginning at the start judges
including federal judges including the
first justices of the Supreme Court were
colored ropes they would wear red robes
trimmed in ermine in the custom of
British judges or some of them wore
robes that were in the colours of the
academic institution from which they had
graduated so much like academics when
they wear regalia at commencement that
was the custom of judges at the time but
John Marshall who was not our first
chief justice but was the foundational
and probably the greatest of chief
justices is the one who changed that
tradition at John Marshalls investiture
he showed up wearing a simple black robe
and soon thereafter his brethren the
other members of the court followed suit
and today all federal judges wear a
simple black robe in deciding cases when
they sit so why do I think that's
important why do I think that reflects
the symbol of the impersonality of the
law because the focus should not be who
is deciding the case the focus shouldn't
be on the judge the judge shouldn't be
drawing attention to herself or himself
the focus should be on the law the judge
should be deciding the case not in
accordance with her personal with her
individual preferences so the black robe
doesn't express individuality and a
judge should not be deciding cases in
accordance with her individual
preferences the black robe symbolizes
that all law all judges share a
dedication to the rule of law that we
are engaged in a common enterprise of
applying the law and
doing our best job at it justice should
not turn on what judge you get it should
turn on what the law requires now you
might be saying to yourselves well
that's all I'm good
but judges are human human beings have
preferences human beings have
commitments and how could humans beings
ever separate out what their personal
preferences are from what the law
requires I insist that that is possible
it is something that every judge must be
vigilant about but it is impossible that
is the nature of the job and that is the
judicial duty I'm going to share with
you a couple of my own techniques that I
use to try to guard against any sort of
bias when I write an opinion I try to
view it through the eyes of the party
that I'm ruling against through the
losing party so I try to imagine that it
is me or someone I love let's imagine
it's a criminal case that it's one of my
own children who's on the other side to
try to check and make sure am i deciding
this case in the most honest way and not
out of any personal bias or personal
sympathy if this was someone who I loved
who was on the line could I honestly say
that this reasoning obviously I would
want to decide the case in favor of my
child right but could I honestly say
that this reasoning is one that I would
apply to someone that I loved dearly and
I do the same thing for colleagues that
might disagree with me so the job of
judges is to sift through arguments
sometimes the arguments in a case
especially at the court of appeals level
will be pretty one-sided and they'll be
pretty easy agreement among the
three-judge panel about what the law
requires but the cases are sometimes
closer and there will be good arguments
on either side and it's the job of the
judge decide which of the arguments is
butter and as I draft an opinion in that
kind of case I do it with an eye towards
what colleagues
likely to disagree with me what would
the dissent think do my arguments hold
up have I really given due weight to
everything on the other side what will
the dissent say about this and if I
write the opinion that way I am really
giving the arguments on the other side
they're full do because when a judge has
tunnel vision when a judge makes a
knee-jerk decision about how a case
should be decided based on how the judge
wants to see it decided then the judge
has a hard time guarding against that
risk of personal preferences creeping in
it's only when the judge disciplines
herself to really consider the best
legal arguments on both sides of a
question that the judge can do her best
job trying to make sure she is adhering
to that Duty of following the law
wherever the law may lead our
foundational constitutional commitment
is to the rule of law and for more than
two centuries the federal judiciary has
worked assiduously if not always
successfully has worked very hard and
mostly successfully to develop and
uphold the rule of law we have an
amazing Constitution and we have an
amazing judicial system we should be
proud of it and we want it to continue
for my own part I became a judge to
contribute to that tradition and I would
have had no interest in the job if the
job was about policy making and about
making policy decisions my interest is
in contributing to our tradition of
judges upholding the rule of law and
there's a lot of time these days about
the courts being mere political
institutions but if we reduce the courts
to mere politics then why do we need
them we already have politicians courts
are not arenas for politics courts are
places where judges discharge the duty
to pull the rule of law and I'm going to
stop there and then invite my students
Stephanie to come up and we'll just have
a little bit of back-and-forth
[Applause]
so to start I'd like to talk with you
about the confirmation process okay it
wasn't that long ago that you went
through it and there was a lot of media
discussion about whether the faith of a
judicial nominee is relevant in the
confirmation process you yourself got
quite a bit of attention on that
question so what role if any should
faith of a nominee have in the
confirmation process
none same or that's not none we have a
long tradition of religious tolerance in
this country and in fact the religious
test clause in the Constitution makes it
unconstitutional to impose a religious
test on anyone who holds public office
so whether someone is you know Catholic
or Jewish or evangelical or Muslim or
has no faith at all is irrelevant to the
job and in fact it's unconstitutional to
consider it as a qualification for
office I think there's been a lot of
public debate about that so I don't
think I have much more to add I think
that that's just clear I do have one
thing that I want to add to that though
I think when you when you step back and
you think about the debate about whether
someone's religion has any bearing on
their fitness for office it seems to me
that the premise of the question is that
people of faith would have a uniquely
difficult time separating out their
moral commitments from their obligation
to apply the law and I think people of
faith should reject that premise all
people of course well or we hope most
people right have deeply held moral
convictions whether or not they come
from faith people who have no faith
people who are not religious have deeply
held moral convictions and it's just as
important for those people to be sure
you know I just spent time talking about
the job of a judge being to set aside
moral convictions personal more
convictions
and personal preferences and follow the
law that's a challenge for those of
faith and for those who have no faith so
I think the public should be absolutely
concerned about whether or not many for
judicial office will be willing and able
to set aside personal preferences be
they moral be they political whatever
convictions they are the public should
be concerned about whether a nominee can
set those aside in favor of following
the law but that's not a challenge just
for religious people I mean that'sthat's
a challenge for everyone and so I think
it's a dangerous road to go down to say
that only religious people would not be
able to separate out moral convictions
from their their duty so in the in the
same way that you you just answered we
separate faith from the law you've
talked about how we separate politics
from the law so how does that map on to
the number of 5-4 decisions in the court
which seemed to often break down along
partisan lines would you say that the
court is becoming more politicized no I
wouldn't and that's that's obviously a
popular narrative right now and it has
been at other points in history as I as
I tell my students when in my former
life is a constitutional law professor I
think that those differences are not
about partisan politics I don't know any
judges who come to the bench with the
aim of saying I am going to bring into
effect the platform of the party with
maybe with which I was once affiliated
that's not true of those who have been
nominated by Democratic presidents and
that's not true of those who have been
nominated by Republican president
presidents so I don't think that 5-4
decisions or splits on courts are
explicable by partisan commitments or by
outcomes in particular cases I think
they're explicable by by starting points
by first order commitments so there are
differences in ways that judges approach
the enterprise of interpreting the
Constitution I'll give you a couple of
examples all judges the
that the original meaning of the
Constitution its history the way that it
was understood by those who ratified it
who drafted it the founding generation
all judges take that as a data point as
relevant those who are committed to
originalism treated as determinative
when the original meaning is discernible
others just treat it as a data point but
one that would not necessarily control
so that will yield different outcomes in
different cases it's the same thing with
constitutional tests some judges take an
approach to the text that says listen if
the text is clear that's non-negotiable
others take an approach to the test that
text that treats it as having a little
bit more play in the joints okay some
judges approach the Constitution saying
there are some constitutional
commitments that we're not going to back
down from because the Constitution
enshrines them but with respect to those
that the Constitution does not speak
we're going to leave it to Democratic
majorities to work out others see the
Constitution as having a more amorphous
and evolving content and speaking to you
know evolving values and majority
evolving values in ways that then
democratic majorities don't have the
freedom to make choices so they're just
different approaches to constitutional
interpretation that will yield different
results and many hot-button cases but
that's a lot different than saying well
it's because such-and-such a judge goes
in and has these particular five
commitments that are consistent with the
Democratic Party platform or the
Republican party platform so it's really
a difference in one's understanding of
the Constitution and of the role of a
judge so you spoke a little bit about
the way in which you approach opinion
writing how you separate your personal
preferences and take an objective view
when President Obama nominated justice
Sotomayor to the Supreme Court he
famously said that judges should be
shaped by
but the as much as by reason and that
quote a common touch of compassion end
quote
is a necessary ingredient in a justice
or a judge so do you think empathy or
compassion have a role to play do they
have a role to play in legal reasoning
and legal writing well I think empathy
and compassion have a role to play in
the life of every human being right I
mean we should all be empathetic and we
should all be compassionate and as
people I think that's something that we
want to encourage do I think it has a
role in legal reasoning I would say no
well I would say yes in this respect I
don't think and I try when I draft
opinions to have this in mind I don't
think judges should ever be harsh so I
don't think I think you should be
compassionate to the losing party who
might find it difficult to read the
opinion I'm aware that the party I'm
ruling against will read the opinion and
so I want it to be not worded harshly
right to be phrased in a way that's kind
and easy to take but should the law be
driven by compassion or empathy and I
would say the answer to that is no
because that gets mixed up and the
judges personal preferences or feelings
so I think when the law requires a
result sometimes the law requires
results that are hard I think I think
sometimes you know that the penalties or
the sentences that statutes impose for
particular crimes I think this would be
something that district judges face all
the time when they sentence criminal
defendants sometimes they don't have a
lot of discretion because of the system
that the statute sets in terms of how
long the sentence must be and that that
might be very hard for them to impose
that sentence if that's what the law
requires you can't have judges saying
you know that's not what I'm going to do
because my heart tells me otherwise so I
think what we want in judges again is
judges who will follow the law and we
want to be compassionate people we
certainly want to be aware of the
effects of our decisions but I think you
get into a dangerous place when you say
that you're gonna follow your heart
and not your head in deciding a case you
you've talked about at least in
conversation with me about how
frequently the Seventh Circuit writes
opinions and you yourself have written
quite a few in criminal cases is that
something that it could has informed
your approach in terms of paying
attention to the language that you're
using and whether you're coming across
those harsh and in those opinions
sorry trying to be conscious when I
write the opinions that the people you
know who I'm reading that let's imagine
that I'm affirming a conviction or
affirming a sentence you know if it were
my child whose conviction was being
affirmed or whose sentence was being
affirmed I would want the opinion
written in a very respectful and well
reasoned way and not in a snide way or
to use it as an opportunity to get like
a some cute lines in or something like
that so yeah I think it's very important
to realize this is serious business that
you're entrusted with heavy
responsibility as a judge and so you
should write your opinions accordingly
this is real stuff and people's Liberty
on the line you've had one opinion that
that drew so many opinions that drew
attention one in particular that I'd
like to talk about you wrote a dissent
in Cantor versus bar which was a Second
Amendment case and in your dissent you
studied founding era documents can you
talk a little bit about the the
background of the case for those of us
who are unfamiliar with it and then talk
about your approach to those large
constitutional questions sure so Cantor
versus Barr was a case in which the
defendant well he he had been convicted
of Medicaid fraud he had stolen he had
sold shoe inserts that didn't actually
comply with the right standards and then
been refunded gotten money for them
anyway it was fraud and he had served
his sentence but under federal law those
who've been convicted of a felony of any
felony lose their gun rights and so they
can't possess have gone thereafter so
Kantor argued that he wasn't a threat
you know this was his only conviction it
wasn't a violent crime
he had discharged his sentence he didn't
use illegal substances you know he was
stable he had a job he was married and
their time had passed since this
conviction and he was not a recidivist
so he argued that it was
unconstitutional to deprive him of his
second Amendment right to possess a
firearm because he did not cause any
danger and the three-judge panel two of
my colleagues rejected that claim and
said that the Second Amendment doesn't
preclude in Cantor's case there was both
a state statute from Wisconsin and then
a federal statute that made it illegal
for felons to possess guns so the
majority said that that was
constitutional and I wrote a dissent
saying that it was unconstitutional it's
unusual at the Court of Appeals level to
encounter a case which requires a deep
dive into founding era documents because
at the Court of Appeals level so many of
cases have already been decided by the
Supreme Court that you're typically
applying precedent you're applying
Supreme Court precedent the Second
Amendment is newer territory the Supreme
Court decided Heller versus United
States just however the District of
Columbia not that long ago and and it
hasn't take it's only taken one other
Second Amendment case since then so
there's just not a lot of precedent out
there so I had to do it a pretty deep
dive into the history of the Second
Amendment and Heller the Supreme Court
case is pretty clear about the fact that
the scope of the Second Amendment needs
to be determined by its history and I
concluded after serving all of the
arguments that historically based
arguments for the constitutionality of
depriving felons of their right to
possess firearms that there was no
blanket authorization to just take guns
that the right to possess a gun away
from someone who committed a felony that
sounds kind of radical to say felons can
have firearms but I think it's because
what the long-standing prohibitions were
and in fact had been even under federal
law until more recently with that
violent felons
couldn't have firearms and there's a
long-standing what the history showed me
is that there's there's been a
long-standing practice of saying that
those who have who pose a threats of
violence to the community cannot have
firearms and that makes sense right
history is consistent with common sense
those who would be risky with guns who
would pose danger with guns then the
state can take guns away but in the
instance of someone who has not the
state has not shown that the person has
demonstrated any risk the mere status of
having committed a felony felony I found
no historical support for saying that
the state was then justified in taking
it away so you know as I said in that
opinion if the state had evidence that
mr. Cantor would have posed some threat
of violence if he'd had a gun then that
would be a different situation but the
mere fact that someone had committed a
felony wasn't enough and you know over
criminalization gets a lot of talk these
days and when you look at the number of
things that are felonies you know you
can you know it's a it's a felony right
now I'm kind of talking up the hip and
I'll see if I can remember exactly which
state it was I think it was
Massachusetts I mean selling pigs
without a license
you know returning out-of-state bottles
for deposits in Michigan can be a felony
when it's over a certain amount and so
there's not really a limit on what
states can choose to define as felonies
and so it seems a little bit odd to say
that the scope of one Second Amendment
right would depend on what a state
chooses to define as a felony or not so
I concluded that the line really isn't
whether someone is a felon or not that
the line is really whether someone is
dangerous or not but dangerous people
shouldn't have guns but simply saying
that someone has committed a felony
isn't a good good enough reason without
markers of dangerousness it was hard I
mean you know at the Supreme Court you
know when I clerked in see when I think
become true or and true or you have so
many briefs from amici so friends of the
court will file briefs and they will
give you all this historical research
and you have excellent advocates and so
the court has less groundwork of its own
to do because the briefing is it's so
rich and the same is not true with the
Court of Appeals you just don't have all
these you know amicus briefs coming in
so my law clerks and I had to do a lot
of research on our own so it was a heavy
lift I bet there's some upcoming Law
Review articles about those so if you're
looking at founding era documents would
you describe yourself as an originalist
and if so could you describe your view
of originalism what what that means to
you yeah yeah I do consider myself to be
an originalist and my view of
originalism you know lists have two
basic commitments one is that the
meaning of the law is fixed as of the
time that it's ratified and then that
the original meaning of that law
controls if it's discernible so
sometimes you know laws will have more
open-ended or constitutional provisions
even might use more open-ended language
like the word reasonableness and the
Fourth Amendment sometimes the language
of a constitutional provision is clear
and if the law is clear an originalist
would say that the judge doesn't have
the discretion to depart from it so I do
consider myself originalist
and I think you know when when I was in
law school I think I started gravitating
towards that as a first year when I took
constitutional Criminal Procedure and
and my professor was not an originalist
but that was my first exposure to
constitutional cases and I I didn't know
I didn't go to Hillsdale College so I
had not studied originalism as an
undergraduate so I wasn't familiar when
I entered law school with originalism as
a theory but I found myself as I read
more and more cases becoming more and
more convinced that the opinions that I
read that took the originalist approach
were right
and then as I progressed through my
studies and then did more theoretical
work I became even more convinced of
that because that's where the
Constitution gets its authority right I
mean we agreed to live by the
Constitution until it's lawfully changed
and judges can't change it that's not
democratic right we change it by the
prescribed process which is Article five
now the Constitution doesn't answer
every question and it gives a lot of
flexibility it gives that flexibility to
Democratic majorities to meet changing
times by passing legislation the
Constitution isn't the panacea that
cures every societal problem we have to
trust our political branches to do that
one final question on a personal note
you are a wife mother of seven law
professor and a federal judge
so can women really have it all and if
you had to give advice to young women at
Hillsdale and other universities for
pursuing a career in the law what would
that look like I think each woman is
called to a unique path I don't think
there's one cookie cutter way that women
should proceed I didn't know exactly
what I wanted my life to look like it
kind of became a work as always it still
is a work in private progress we will
celebrate the hundredth anniversary of
the 19th amendment next year which gave
women the right to vote and I think that
we should celebrate the ability of women
to not only cast their ballots but to
participate in both the private and the
public spheres in so many ways that our
grandmothers are not able to so yes
one thing I often think when when I'll
get asked this question a lot as I think
most working mothers do about balancing
career and family one thing I think that
is really important not to lose sight of
is that we are so fortunate as women
living in 2019 to have so many more
doors open to us and so many choices but
I think as part of that conversation I
always want to be careful never to
devalue the choices that women make that
are different women shouldn't have to be
cookie cutters so some women have the
flexibility to be able to stay home with
children I have seven children and I'm
also the oldest of seven children and I
have five sisters and three of us worked
full-time two of us work part-time and
one stays home with her children and she
homeschools them and she probably works
harder than the rest of us um so I think
we should celebrate and try to make
possible and support and think
creatively about ways to provide
childcare for women who are in the
workplace and then I think we should
also celebrate the choices like my
sister Eileen who is home with her
children and my own mother make two to
stay home with their children I just
think that one freedom that we should
really celebrate as women is that we
don't have to just follow a path that
seems like the one that people tell us
that we have to follow and we don't just
have to think what people tell us that
we might have to think as women that
we're really free and that if you want
to live a life that looks a little bit
different I mean you know my friend I
have seven children two of them are
adopted from Haiti and our youngest has
Down syndrome and you know my when when
my son Benjamin was born and he was in
the NICU my friend my dear friend or
them for a long time was sitting with me
with it it was a very difficult time he
was on oxygen she was holding my hand
she looked up at me and she said did you
have to be so competitive you
had the most most interesting Christmas
card on the mantle choices to have a
life that looks different or odd I mean
you can be free to be different and you
can stay home with children or you can
work but we should respect the choices
that all women make in that regard in
the contributions that all women
contribute do you have any final closing
thoughts gosh I don't think so it was so
grateful that you all came tonight and
it was wonderful to be with you
okay thankthank you judge them and thank
you Stephanie of that interview that was
wonderful I have I have two things for
you one is it's not notre-dame green but
it's Hillsdale blue
and of course I do have a last final
final question for you which is what is
your position about Hillsdale students
as law clerks and thank you and thank
all those a lot of people are watching
on our live streaming both on campus and
elsewhere I thank them for joining us
thank you all for joining us and have a
wonderful evening
thank you very much
you